so from everything you've ever seen all
the bodybuilders you've ever seen who's
your top five best physiques so I know
you've dialed up in no particular order
no no I won't order like put it in well
in order counting everything not just
body everything Arnold has to be first
who's second I would go with you know
and you got to go by certain years I
would say Arnold 73 74 which I believe
was his best I was there I saw it
even though 75 it was very good and I
saw or a man I own the outtakes at one
time so I saw old 110 hours of pumping
iron but I still think 73 74 was his
peak 75 in my opinion he came back just
to do the movie and this and that
it wasn't gung-ho like before you gotta
remember 73 when he competed he had
tours his knee guest posing after the 72
Olympia in South Africa gets posing for
reg Park need a knee surgery so he came
back with a vengeance but people said he
wouldn't come back and he those two
years he was right on the money
Dorian Yates in 93 I've one of these
pictures here who's goes this this one
with the original picture to think was
taken by Kevin Horton where he had the
pants around his ankles that was before
he tore anything you put him at second I
don't know I don't know how to put a
second in the top five Sherman okay five
okay Lee Haney Lee Haney at his peak
again what was Lee any weaknesses he had
none right there I can't go up by two
guys if after I left
it's fine I'm saying two up two or three
over that's plenty of names there up two
or three yeah I guess the other two
would be Ronnie and Sergio Sergio Oliva
right so you're leaving out a lot of
names you take me top five you got leave
somebody out okay
so Sergio for you and then Ronnie at
their time the big idea and who they're
competing against in their era
I'm not taking Sergio from 68 and
putting them next to Coleman of 2001
different ear at different time at that
time Sergio in 1960 nobody would compete
against him he was so good you know he
was he was on being
you know Lee Haney had his Pico kid it
was more pros than but Lee Haney was
very good and very complete and very big
what was Lee Haney's weakness I mean if
he had a weakness a little bit
it was just posing and he worked on it
you know because we judged posing that
you know Dorian to a weakness was
probably worked on it
[Music]